Think of this like a Python.
It's 1 times the value of one step to the left--1 times the value one step to the right--
minus twice the value at the original position.
And now we have to insert this Python into itself.
If you look at this one, one step to the left, we have to go one further step to the left
times 1, this 1 times -2 and this 1 times 1.
So one further step to the left is this one, two steps to the left minus 2.
This was the one, one step to the left--1 is our original one.
Similarly for the right one, we go one further step to the right and so on and so on.
One step to the left and minus 2 times the original one.
For the central one, we have to multiply the Python by -2, so we've got -2, 4, -2,
which boils down to 1 times the value 2 steps to the left minus 4 times the value 1 step to the left
6 times the value at the center minus 4 times the value of 1 step to the right
and 1 times the value 2 steps to the right.